hey thanks i meant everyone can hear me
good
um so it's been about uh 30 years
since garbled circuits came out of the
scene in the in the 80s
maybe it's a good time to sit back and
and see where we've been and i think
garbled circuits uh 2pc mpc in general
garbage garbled circuits
specifically have been a real success
story for crypto
and that's kind of the story that i want
to tell today
in terms of a practical adoption of
these crypto techniques
i'm just going to start right out and
i'm going to show uh
technical all the technical details in
this talk because they're
they're simple they're easy to
understand and they're elegant i think
everyone can appreciate them
so i'm going to start off um right away
and
refresh everyone's memory about garbled
circuits right this is a
this is like i don't know your first
lecture in the
in some grad crypto course so here is a
boolean circuit
uh this is actually some sort of
comparison circuit i actually i
i worked it out it took me it took me a
significant amount of time but this is a
this is some sort of a comparison
circuit uh
comparing two uh two-bit numbers um
i i forget how it works now but um each
uh
each gate in the circuit is associated
with the a truth table
um i had to look up the symbols for it
was a disaster
um the little bubble is a knot right so
you see
this this is this negates the first wire
so you see the
the true is yeah so good um it's all
coming back to us now
so uh the idea to garble a circuit is
for each wire
in the circuit we'll pick two uh two
random crypto keys i'll call them wire
labels
uh so a zero wire label and one
wire label on each wire um the wire
label with the subscript zero is going
to correspond to
false and the subscript one is going to
correspond to true
and so every place that in the truth
tables replace the
the semantic values with these uh
abstract wire labels as encodings of
true and false
and the big idea is to encrypt each gate
so i will encrypt for example the output
wire label
using a pair of input wire labels that
means if you
if you know a0 and b0 that's like false
false then you should learn the output
wire label for false
and we'll do that for every single uh
every single gate in the circuit this is
what we get and so this collection
of uh four ciphertexts per
gate in the circuit i'll call that the
garbled circuit so this is a big
cryptographic
bundle of information and
we can encode truth values
with a garbled encoding so up here is a
is an encoding of
let's say one zero zero one on these
wires so i just picked
the appropriate wire label for each wire
that's a garble encoding along the wire
and so now what this allows you to do if
you know the garbled circuit
and you know a garbled encoding of the
input
then what we observe is that for each
gate you should
you should only be able to open exactly
one of these ciphertexts and then you'll
learn exactly one wire label for each
for the output wire that's the invariant
you'll learn exactly one label for each
wire and we can go through i spent a lot
of time on this slide so i'll
i'll let you see all of my hard work
did you give me steak there's a mistake
no
okay we'll talk offline
okay so we eventually get a garbled uh
we eventually get a garbled
encoding of the output it's false in
this case um
whatever that means with respect to the
inputs so that's that's the basic
this is the baseline classical yahoo's
garbled circuit construction
and we love garbled circuits the
classical application of which
is a secure two-party computation so
alice and bob have their private inputs
alice can generate a garbled circuit she
can send the garbled
uh encoding of her input so the circuit
has input wires for alice and for bob
she sends the goblin coating of her
input
she sends the the uh all all the wire
labels for
the uh the output wires um
we need to arrange for bob to pick up a
garbled encoding of his
input and that's easy to do with the one
out of two oblivious transfer
so that's really nice and once bob has
the garbled circuit and the garbled
encoding of the input he can evaluate
the circuit
he can decode it with the output y
labels and send back the result this is
a secure protocol
uh in the presence of semi honest
adversaries
and there are many many more
applications of garbled circuits
both in theory and in practice i stole
this list from
billare huang ragaway paper and they
really recognized
uh that the process of garbling a
computation should be recognized as like
a fundamental crypto
cryptographic primitive you know just
like a block cipher is a fundamental
primitive
um that really kind of reflects how
important this uh
primitive has been um in the last 30
years
so uh here's the the syntax
of of garbling uh as a fundamental
primitive
i don't want to go into too much detail
but i'll just say a little bit about the
security properties it's important to
understand what we're aiming for
maybe the most important one is that if
i give you a garbled circuit
and a garbled input and this decoding
information
then you learn nothing beyond the output
of the circuit
and that's the important property that
we need in the in the
two pc yao's protocol there are some
other properties
one that i'll talk to about one that
i'll talk about later is authenticity
if i just give you a garbled circuit and
a garbled input but i don't i
i withhold the decoding information then
it should be hard for an adversary to
generate a valid garbled output
other than the one that he's uh supposed
to
supposed to get so it should be hard to
falsify the uh
the the output um so those are the
security properties that we're after
and so the the the focus of this talk
is uh is optimizations of garbled
circuits throughout the years
and there are different parameters that
we can think of optimizing we could
optimize the hardness assumption that's
uh the size of the garbled circuit the
the number of ciphertexts that are sent
per gate
and also the cost of computation and in
this talk i'll really focus on the size
just as an objective metric and this
is uh this is bored out in practice
most of these applications of garbled
circuits we find that
the communication overhead is the major
bottleneck and so reducing the size
is really the key factor i'll talk a
little bit about computation also
and i will not care about the hardness
assumption
at all for this the purposes of this
talk yeah does
expressiveness of the circuit language
does that count in size or you know if
you
allow a different type of circuit like
an arithmetic circuit
um so the the practical instantiations
of garbling are just
boolean circuits and there are
theoretical constructions uh
for arithmetic circuits that are
more of a heavy machinery and they use
lattices and stuff so i won't focus on
that
in fact i'll focus when i say size
i i'm actually talking about concrete uh
concrete size
of things that are implemented in
practice there are there are lots of
things in
in crypto like a functional encryption
that you can that you can
you can express as a garbled circuit in
this framework
they have asymptotically better size but
the constants are huge they use heavy
machinery like fhe and
obfuscation and so i really focus on the
the boolean circuits
the boolean circuit constructions
so that's kind of my baseline
okay so this graph kind of tells this is
the story that i want to tell with this
talk
this is the average number of bits
per gate that you need to garble
different circuits so to garble the aes
circuit
back in 1990 it took four times
uh four times the security parameter
that was the cost
per gate to garble the aes circuit and
now the cost
is i think it's like 0.4 times the
security parameter
average number of bits that you need per
gate in the aes circuit
and so i want to tell the story of how
we got from from the
dotted portion of the line uh where no
one knew anything
and to the current state of the art um
that means i would talk about
practical uh would lead to two to the
minus lambda
security or what what do you mean by so
yeah security parameter
think of think of it as the length of
the the wire labels
no no but i mean how does it relate to
security
i mean if you if you assume that aes is
like two to the minus 128 security yeah
yeah but also the garbling security
you're comparing these
with the same level of security all the
different uh
yeah this is this is the the size of the
garbled circuit and so that's kind of
it can be a really fair comparison with
the same security parameters
security analysis that would allow you
or maybe the security analysis doesn't
matter and you just take the best
instance my question is
there are possible attacks against the
most heavily optimized variants
that do not yeah okay i understand the
question i don't think there's
among the constructions that i'll show i
don't think there's
very much difference at all in the you
know the reason that we're getting these
improvements
doesn't really show up in the security
proof in terms of like introducing extra
slack in the
in the reduction if that's what you're
asking so i think this the slack in the
security reduction is
is is pretty equivalent between all of
these
i thought i'd make a really bold
prediction if you this is kind of a
linear this is kind of a straight line
and so if you
if you extrapolate i think 2026
is going to be a great year to be
studying crypto and then all garbled
circuits will
will cost nothing so um
so so watch for the proceedings of
crypto 2026
maybe that's when yes it's broken
yeah when aes is broken then the secure
protocol is just i send my input
good yeah hugo will have the uh
google 2026 okay
okay so like i said i want to get into
the actual details of these
constructions
one thing that i glossed over in my
first slide was that
i didn't talk about the position of
these ciphertexts within
these four ciphertexts the relative
position leaks information
for example if you end up opening the
third ciphertext then it's the
third row of the truth table that's a
zero because we all know what this gate
is
um that means in the classical
construction we have to permute these
four ciphertexts
um and that means that when you evaluate
you have to trial decrypt
uh all four of them and you have to
identify when you've
decrypted successfully you have to know
when you found
the single cipher text that you're
supposed to be able to open
and i looked and i couldn't find that
anyone knew what
yao had in mind it was a theoretical
construction after all
who knows how how much he thought this
would be
in practice in the year 2015
but the the gmw paper has a
just an account of garbled circuits they
use
actually public key uh crypto
to instantiate these uh ciphertexts in
the garbled circuit
uh later lindelin pinkus had uh
they they wrote a paper that was a
formal proof of vl's construction they
chose to do like a nested encryption
it was symmetric encryption but it it
had the property that you could tell
whether you
you were decrypting successfully um i
think the public key crypto
in the gmw paper was so that there were
public keys floating around so you could
tell when you got the correct secret key
that's my
guess but i don't know if that's i don't
know if that's true
i couldn't find anyone who knew what
really happened
um
just to make sure it's staying
theoretical
okay good
to verify the secret key was
okay but we're not focusing on the the
public key aspect anyway um
we don't need public key um so the so i
want to start
uh so everything is kind of murky at
this point uh i want to start
uh rattling off these different
optimizations they're very they're very
nice and elegant uh
um so here's the the first one
uh so beaver macaulay ragaway in 1990
uh had this observation they said
uh here's a there's a garbled gate for
each wire
in for each wire label we'll assign it a
random color
um and the two wire labels the two
labels for each wire have opposite color
and the color is kind of it's randomly
associated sometimes the false gets red
sometimes false gets blue
so the color is totally independent of
the semantic value
and we'll include the color in the wire
label itself usually as the last
bit of the wire label so if you hold a
wire label in your hand you can see what
color it is
and now look at these four cipher texts
you have all four different
combinations of the uh of the two uh
of the red blue colors and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to canonically
order these four ciphertexts
so in my world red red is always first
red blue is is always second
i'm always going to order the four
ciphertexts in that way
and that means when you hold
when you hold an input to this gate
you'll see what colors it is
here you have blue red and in my world
that's always the third ciphertext you
always go straight to the third
ciphertext and decrypt it
you don't have to do a trial decryption
of all four you don't have to have extra
redundancy
in these ciphertexts to tell whether
you've decrypted the right one
in fact it allows these uh ciphertexts
to be really
cryptographically simple objects they
only need the simple one-time security
uh like a like a simple one-time pad
essentially
and so i want to take a little tangent
and talk about the
different instantiations that you can
use for these uh for these gate level
encryptions maybe one of the earliest
one was from nauer pinkus and sumner
using using two prfs in this way so here
a and b are the input the the wire
labels of the input wires
c is the payload it's the wire label of
the output
label of that circuit or that gate
let's see so here is kind of the the
first
one and fair play was the first
implementation of yao's garbled circuit
they used this
uh this encryption they used sha-256 as
a prf
and they didn't run their implementation
on aes but i extrapolated i think it
would take about six seconds
using 2004 hardware this is a totally
unfair comparison i'm talking about
running times
from things from different from from
different years it's not a fair
comparison but
just to give you an idea of the order of
magnitude of these things so a couple
seconds to
to garble an aes circuit here
well one hash is always better than two
hashes i guess
and so another thing you could do is you
could take a hash you model it as a
random
oracle let's say and just hash
everything together
you use that as a as a mask to the
payload
this was suggested by lindo pinkus and
smart
there's an implementation from shellat
and shen in 2012
they used 250 shot 256 here um
i mean it's eight years later hardware
is faster um and now this is like
tenths of a second to garble aes um
but we know that uh implementing
implementations of block ciphers are
faster than hash functions
so let's try to use a block cipher you
can use aes 256 this is kind of
convenient you have a
256 bit key which is like two wire
labels and the block itself is
is 128 it's like one wire label uh
that's significantly fast well
it's a non-trivial amount faster it's
like 30 faster
because you can use a hardware
accelerated aes instructions
but then these are kind of blown out of
the water so belaradol
have they observed that the the major
cost in using aes
is the key schedule and so what if we
can get rid of the key schedule
altogether that should be faster
so let's use aes with a constant key
and use this construction they proved it
was a
secure thing to plug in it's kind of a
non-standard
assumption to make about aes it assumes
that uh when you fix
when you fix a public uh publicly known
constant
as the aes key the thing that you get
should look like an ideal permutation
this is kind of the flavor of an ideal
cipher assumption
on aes but the results are pretty
staggering so now we're
now we're in the measuring the costs due
to garbage the whole aes circuit in in
than
microseconds
yeah this is just yeah this is like the
one side i have about computation
um
the ansi standard for seconds i don't
think has changed
these are the seconds that were reported
in this paper extrapolated
so the the hardware is
we we're we can take credit for advances
in hardware right
crypto's gotten better because advances
in hardware and that's kind of folded
into this like
comparison if you just measure stuff in
seconds is my question oh it's totally
not fair but i mean
i don't think hardware advances have
accounted for the entirety of this
improvement that's maybe my point but
yeah this is totally unfair that's why i
also want to focus on size for the rest
of the talk which is
legitimately fair comparison curiosity i
mean how easy
is to use those skins because in
principle it was like really trivial to
use to make a fair comparison you would
just like you know click a button and
just recompute it like this here
because my understanding one of the
things is like public key cryptography
the reason it's not used it's like this
libraries are super painful to use it's
like
oh or is it getting to the level where
you just click a button install and
can run it the implementation in this
paper is
is is pretty simple you push a button
you
you give a circuit out pops a garbled
circuit um
but they they only implemented this uh
they only instantiated their encryption
with this yeah
do you guys want to do the actual work
but i mean it might be actually a good
thing to
make sure that you do something for your
paper but
for people to use so then you know you
can make comparisons and actually
use it in real yeah so speaking of fair
comparison the next talk in the program
is from yehuda
uh his talk will give like another data
point here and
maybe a little bit more comparison not
an entire
summary of the entire history of the
world but
more comparisons here and focusing on
the hardness assumption here
and the trade-off
see blue blue is true here and false
here so the the the color is
chosen randomly apart from the semantic
value yeah
yeah it's independent of the semantic
value so it can be the basis of ordering
the
okay good um so this is all i wanted to
say about computation
i want to focus on on the reduction in
garbled circuit size
uh here's our here's our baseline uh i
want to focus mostly on this first
column
how big is a is a cipher is a garbled
circuit
uh the classical construction i don't
know it's probably pretty big
the ciphertext have some redundancy
maybe some public key mechanisms
point and permute um we have four
ciphertexts per for a garbled gate
okay so it seems like you know there's
four possible input combinations to the
gate how could
anything be cheaper than that so here's
the
you know the the first hole in in the
wall they get us
breaking through now our pinkish and
summoner had this idea of row reduction
and the idea is pretty simple so i
described garbled circuits where
for each uh wire you choose the true and
false wire labels randomly
but what if we don't choose them
randomly what if there's a
better way of choosing these wire labels
so what we'll do is we'll look at the
these four cipher text we'll see what
ciphertext is the first one
like the red red one is always the first
one what will be the payload of that
ciphertext in this case it's c1
so instead of choosing c1 randomly i'll
choose c1 to be
the value that when encrypted causes
this first ciphertext to be zero
right that's what this says the value
that when encrypted under a0 b1 gives me
all zeros cipher text i can do that
because this is just like a
this encryption is like generate a
pseudorandom
mask and do a one-time pad so this e is
like a
is a is like a permutation i can it's
legitimate for me to write this
so now the first cipher i'll choose c1
in that way always
that'll always make the first cipher
text all zeros i don't have to send it
now we just have to
agree that if you get red red you should
just imagine the all zero cipher text
and i don't have to send it
so that's maybe surprising like wow four
seemed like the
the reasonable number for a garbled
circuit now we can do three now now
we really get our wheels moving and
thinking maybe
maybe by 2026 everything will be free um
okay so we update our scoreboard uh we
went from four to three that's garbled
row reduction
uh three which is suggested there may be
other kinds of row reduction that are
not three
um can you explain the other two columns
there sorry
what's the garbage okay so the garble
the cost to garble
um the cost to garble
oh this is confusing
so when you garble the circuit you still
have to perform this this this this you
do four calls to the
this encryption and the cost to evaluate
is we're using point and permute you
just have to find
uh find the correct place and then then
uh
then decrypt that so depending on
whether you're using
this hash instantiation or pseudorandom
function
uh four calls to the hash if you're
using that instantiation or eight calls
to the prf
and then to evaluate one call the hash
two calls of the prf
but that won't be the main focus i
really wanna i really wanna i'm excited
more excited about this column i guess
um okay it's 2008 now in the meantime
fair play
uh has been the first implementation of
garbled circuits
and some people are starting to think
well maybe this there's something to
this maybe we can implement
this and it can actually be practical uh
so kolesnikov and schneider had this
idea of free xor so i draw an xor
gate if you're not familiar with the
circuit symbols that's an xor gate
and instead of writing the y labels as i
have been
i'll write them in this way so there's
the false wire labels a and the true one
is a
plus some offset so every wire has an
offset i can always write
things in this form these three wires
maybe have different offsets but the
idea behind free
xor is make all the wires have the same
offset
so there's a common delta for all of the
wires so it's
false is a b and c true is a plus delta
b plus delta c plus delta
what does that buy us instead of
choosing
the output wire label randomly i'll
choose it to just be the xor of the two
false
output y labels and now what happens
suppose i have
exactly one label here and one label
here and i xor them together
like xo the false and false i get the
false y label false and true i get the
true y label
true and false i get true true and true
the two deltas cancel out it's xor and i
get false i get the semantics of
of xor and all the evaluator had to do
was xor the two wire labels together
um the knee as the generator of the
garbled circuit didn't have to send
anything at all
the xor gate was totally free of
communication it was free of computation
if
it if you consider an xor of strings to
be free
um so that's great that's that's how we
do
xor gates um
let's make sure we have it broken what's
that
delta is random it's a secret that the
generator of the garbled circuit knows
so you'll get something you don't know
if it's going i guess you don't know
yeah you you get this bundle you don't
know yeah
you can use the same delta for all games
right yeah you have to use the same
delta for all gates
because you want every wire that touches
an xor gate to look like this
um so this is how you garble xor gates
let's make sure we haven't broken
other kinds of gates so we still have to
garble
other kinds of gates like here's an and
gate and if i garble it i'll get this
kind of a table
i can still do row reduction
to change it from four to three
ciphertexts so that's good
but i want you to look closely at these
ciphertexts delta is the secret
that's known only to the garbler it's
not known to the evaluator
and it's appearing as a key and also as
a payload of these ciphertexts
and that means we need some kind of a
circularity
assumption for this to work so whatever
however we instantiate this uh
gate level encryption scheme there needs
to be some kind of a circularity
assumption
so just think of delta as a secret um
so if if we're using random oracles this
is fine
um this is we haven't broken anything
but just something to be aware of
yeah what does it do to a circuit if you
have to like
now you have to find like find a
representation of the circuit that
really maximizes the number of xor gates
yes is that
well understood it's uh it's np hard
right
uh claudia you give a nice rom session
to talk about this paper that no one
knows about
about no but everyone knows about it
okay
yeah so um yeah i mean this
this leads to a incentive to make
circuits with as few and gates as
possible and
um people do this i i don't
i think it's it's an it'd be hard
problem to optimize the number of and
gates for sure
or co-np-hard or something
yeah actually the improvement in that
first graph that i showed
the reason aes is such an amazing
looking line in that graph is because
people have done this for aes the aes
garbled circuit is like 80
xor gates um which means it's 80
free so
before we get to the 3x show we're
hiding what every cable is
and now we're telling you where all that
circuits are
so it's security that's true so
throughout this whole thing i'm assuming
that both parties know the circuit and
that's a fair assumption for the
the two pc application we both agree on
the circuit that we're evaluating
but here you're you're absolutely right
like i'm asking the evaluator to do
different things
when he gets to an xor gate versus an
and gate and before i could cut it sort
of disguise the truth table of the gate
so for some applications maybe you're
right the free xor is not appropriate
but
um for most applications this is
this is all right but but yeah that's a
good observation
yeah if you really care you can use a
universal circuit um
right um yeah these can be done just
with prf
and i think the the focus of yehuda's
talk is about the the assumption that
you
use so think of free xor is requiring
random oracle that's
that's a good first approximation these
two don't um
yeah yeah who to talk is about how much
do you have to trade off if you uh
if you don't want random oracle you want
standard assumptions
don't miss it okay so three ciphertexts
is
is great um
three is such a big number why can't we
do two so here uh so pincus said i'll
have this
really clever idea to to garble a gate
with just two ciphertexts
um and this is actually the most
complicated
uh the most complicated construction but
it's still
simple everyone can understand it so
there's imagine the four different
uh possible input combinations you could
have to this gate
the input wire labels and use them to
derive four different keys
so if you know a zero b zero you'll be
able to get t k one
you'll you'll be able as the evaluator
you'll only be able to get exactly one
of those
i wanna set things up so that if you
learn let's say k2 you should learn c1
which is
the true output y label uh and so on so
how can i arrange that for
for that to happen let's take all the
ones that should let you learn zero
so k one k three k four i'm gonna think
of them as
as points in in a finite field uh gf gf2
the n
there's a unique degree two polynomial
passing through these points
i'll call it p and
let's take the other point k2 and i'll
strangely take p5 and p6
those are three points there's a unique
degree two polynomial passing through
those let's call it q
now i have polynomials that are red and
blue
i'm going to choose the output wire
labels to be
p 0 and q 0 so the zero points of these
polynomials
and i'm going to choose the garbled like
the garbled gate
to be p5 and p6 this is the information
that i'm going to give you as part of
the garbled circuit
i claim that this works so if you're
evaluating the scarborough circuit what
do you do
let's suppose you have a1 b0 so that
means you'll be able to learn
k3 right you have a1 b0 you learn k3 so
you know k3
you know p5 and p6 you'll interpolate
you'll get the red polynomial in this
case evaluate that polynomial at 0
and yes that's exactly the false output
y label that's what you're supposed to
learn
if instead you would had a 0 b 1 you
would learn k2
you would interpolate you would get the
blue polynomial you would evaluate it to
zero you get
the true output wire label that's what
you're supposed to learn so when you see
the whole picture now
it kind of makes sense right you always
have these two points if you take
interpolate with any one of these four
you'll get either the red or the blue
polynomial
with exactly the semantics of what this
gate is supposed to be
so before you talk does anybody did
anybody know about this paper
or is it like a well-known paper
more people don't understand
this goes through with just the prf um
you have to you have to understand like
secret sharing now to do the proof but
it's not so bad
even i've written the proof the the one
problem with this
approach so we got we got a garbled gate
down to
two ciphertexts now
this is for an and gate you can do a
similar thing for xor gate
the well the problem is you can't do
free xor now free xor means
you need the the two output wire labels
to have an xor of delta
but now you really have no control over
c0 c1 you can't ensure that they always
have an xor of delta
so this is incompatible with uh free xor
that's too bad so now now we can do any
gate for two
or we can do free xor and do zero and
three and i really don't like this
because
now there's like sometimes free xor is
better sometimes this
row reduction is better
so this only this can be done just with
the prf
um so if you care about assumptions you
might prefer this
and i think i don't know if it's in
their paper but i think
addressing your question i think with
this two ciphertext thing you can
obscure the the truth table of the gate
so
i i think that's probably true
um so if you if you need that property
as well
okay so let's fast forward to last year
or rewind to last year whichever
your point of reference is um so the
flexor paper was with uh
myself and vlad and payman and
we wanted to sort of we wanted to sort
of find something that was
you know better than both of these and
so here is one idea we had so here's a
wire and a circuit
all by itself it has an offset of delta
one
and suppose i'm not really happy with
this delta one offset i'd prefer if it
was a delta two offset i wanna
transfer the delta one offset into a
delta two offset because maybe delta two
is be a more convenient offset for me
you know downstream of this wire so i
can imagine that there is a unary
identity gate i had to look this one up
for sure like this is a buffer gate
you're used to seeing this with a little
bubble at the end that's a not cave so
without the bubble it's just the buffer
gate
if you learn anything from this talk
maybe you learned this
remember the symbols of the
wiring okay so this is a unary identity
gate it's a truth table is really simple
and i'll just do what i have always done
i'll encrypt
uh encrypt the output wire label using
the appropriate input wire label
so that's good that cost me two cipher
text oh but wait i don't really care
what a star is
so instead of choosing a start random
i'll choose it to be the thing that
makes this first ciphertext go away
good so i can i can translate the offset
of a wire to anything i want using just
one ciphertext
i'll use this little uh notation for
that so delta 1 to delta 2
means this gadget so at a cost of one
ciphertext i change the uh
i change the offset of a wire okay let's
let's revisit an xor gate
so yeah
i don't think we ever want it to be
necessarily related so
um good it could though i think the
proof would go through
so let's revisit an xor gate
here these three wires touching the gate
have different uh offsets if they all
have the same offset i would do
free xor but they don't and for some
reason that's going to be beneficial for
me i want them to be have different
offsets
but i guess just for the purposes of
this xor gate
one thing i could do is just translate
these offsets
into delta c which is where the output
should be
these each cost one cipher text and now
these two wires
like really touching the xor gate have
delta c offset they all have the same
offset
this is a free xor and so the total cost
here
the total cost here is one ciphertext
for each of these adjustments
and then the xor is free so this whole
little contraption has two
across of two cipher texts um
which doesn't seem like we're making
progress
but on the other hand if if this wire
was already suitable for me if it was
already the
offset that i wanted then i don't have
to do anything and now this this xor
gate costs one
and if this guy was already delta c i
don't have to do anything it just
collapses to free xor
so overall i can do an xor gate
at a cost of zero one or two ciphertext
and it depends on how many of these
offsets are distinct
right i want many of them to collide
and this gets us to a combinatorial
optimization problem
i want to figure out an offset to give
to each wire
to minimize the total cost of the xor
gates
but i can also throw in an additional
constraint that allows us to be
compatible
with the two ciphertext row reduction
for the and gates
right so this is what i do for xor gates
for and gates i'll do
the pssw paper with the
with two ciphertexts and i just get this
combinatorial optimization
problem to make the the the xor gates as
as minimal as possible um our paper does
some other things too but this
this is the important thing we do in in
terms of the size of the garbled circuit
um so we can get an and gate at a cost
of two
we can get an xor gate for either zero
one or two depending on some
uh structural properties of the circuit
and usually it's a zero or a one
and so in practice we tried a bunch of
circuits it does seem to be better
it uses the ideas of free xor so it has
the same
circularity problem as free xor
but it's a little bit smaller or
significantly smaller in some cases
okay so we're nearing the finish line i
still have some time that's good
um so the latest and greatest is some
joint work with uh
sami who's here say hi to him and and
david evans
um it's this idea called half gates and
i'll start out with this totally
philosophical question
like well let's imagine that the garbler
knows in advance that on one wire
for example this wire i'm garbling a
circuit i know in advance you will get
the false
wire label maybe maybe that will be
helpful
spoiler alert it will be helpful
okay so i know that you're going to get
the false wire label here
that means this and gate collapses to
it'll always output zero right you've
got a false
input to an and gate so i could just if
i knew that you were always having the
false y label i could just garble
this uh unary gate that always outputs
zero
it looks like this right
if i knew that you're going to get true
then
this gate becomes a identity gate
right if you set one wire of an and gate
to true you get an identity gate that's
the residual
i can i could garble that in that case
right so the garbler knows
whether he's here or here somehow we've
we've assumed that the garbler knows
whether he's in the left case of the
right case he'll do the right thing
um let me collapse these two and i'll
just i'll just write uh
i'll write it like this okay so
that's good i'll i can use this idea of
row reduction instead of choosing c
at random i'll choose c to make this
first cipher text disappear
good this cost me this cost me a total
of one ciphertext
so the answer is you know the question
is what if the garbler knows in advance
uh what uh wire label the evaluator will
hold
the answer is well that means we can
just get away with one cipher text
why we should care about that i'll get
to i'm hiding the details of the point
in permute because
because if i back up these two
ciphertexts are permuted according to
their color bits we
we do the right thing to uh it's it's
not difficult but
you have to do that um
already knows that you're saying the
recipient doesn't know why then
you just can't get rid of the gate if
it's identity focus the previous
label i mean just collapse the circuit
why do you need to still do this stuff
yeah you have to you have to trust me
that it'll all work out in the end
i'm saying why don't you just collapse
before garblings you're saying if you
know the result of this wire
is yeah only the garbler knows the
evaluator doesn't
but i'm going to ask the complimentary
question uh what if
only the evaluator knows one input to a
wire and then i'll combine these two at
the end and it'll
magically all work out um so suppose
i'm evaluating a circuit and and i
i come to have this y label b and and i
come to learn that this is
the wire label that i'm holding is
actually encodes false usually i don't
know what
truth value i have what if i somehow
learn that i'm holding the false
wire label and then i can behave
differently
based on whether i have true or false
that's the key so
if i know i have false then
i know i'm going to learn the false
output wire label
so the the garbler can just arrange okay
if if you learn that if you learn that
you have a false y label here's an
encryption of the false output wire
label
and if you know that you have falsies
this is the ciphertext that you'll
decrypt
if i know that i have the true wire
label then again this
becomes like an identity gate and what i
need to do is transfer
the truth value on this a wire into the
c wire
and i claim that it suffices for the
garbler to give me this value a x or c
so let's see what happens if i have the
true wire label down here and i have a
i'll decrypt this second ciphertext i'll
get a xor c
and that allows me to learn false here
i'm transferring the truth value from
here to here
on the other hand if i had the true wire
label up here i would xor
a plus c i would get the true y label up
here
um right so i'm transferring the truth
value along that top
along that top line
and then we'll use our standard trick
instead of choosing c at random i'll
choose c to make this first ciphertext
disappear
and now this just costs a total of one
so if somehow we can tell the evaluator
what
truth value he has on this wire then we
can get away with one ciphertext
and what's interesting here is that the
evaluator
kind of does very different things based
on whether he has uh
the true or the false wire label right
we need him to know because we're asking
him to do different things in those two
different cases
okay so that's bizarre like what is the
purpose of this in the real world no one
knows what values are along these wires
um so the the insight is the we have a
clever way of combining
uh these two types of half gates we call
them
so imagine you have an and gate in the
circuit a and b are bits
let's imagine that you introduce this
extra bit r
our xor with itself is nothing this is
fine i'm going to distribute the and
across the xor and i get this
which makes no sense
what if the garbler chose the value r
and what if we somehow arrange for the
evaluator to learn a plus r which is a
single bit
in the clear that means that
this is an and expression and a
x or r is known to the evaluator
this is an and expression and r is known
to the garbler
right and so that means i can garble
this whole contraption
uh this left bracketed thing is one
ciphertext the right bracketed thing is
one ciphertext this xor in the middle is
free
it's free xor because everything i did
before was with free xor maybe i forgot
to mention that
so you put these two halves together in
this clever way you get a
you get an and gate it's compatible with
free xor and it only costs two
ciphertexts
total and if you're wondering where
these where this r
thing comes from you can actually
basically get it for free everything
that we're already doing
includes this r so if r is like the
color bit
of of false for instance then
okay the the garbler certainly knows the
association between colors and truth
value the garbler knows this
color association the evaluator knows
the color of their own wire
and those two pieces of information are
secret share of the truth value
so the evaluator already has his own
color bit
and and you can you can collapse you
know
present it this way for educational
purposes you collapse it all together
express it in terms of the colors on the
wires
and you get the and gate that costs two
in a way that's compatible with uh
with three xor you already knew
how to how to make it two cypher tests
before but now you want to make it
comparable with
tricks yeah it's these two lines right
that are
we could do two before but not in a way
that was compatible
with three xor and yeah now we did
so before i didn't like it because like
these three things were
one of these three was best for
different classes of functions now this
is best
and the assumption is exactly like three
yeah it's exact same assumptions three
free xr
that's a typo archaeological artifact
that should say hash they should all say
hash anyway
same assumption steve how many
do you have any idea roughly how many
gates you will actually be in the
position where you know
one of your infrastructures so obviously
the input gates you know what your
inputs are but after that
how far can you propagate it normally
well this little gadget
is for all of the internal we introduce
like these extra conceptual gates
where we've set it up so that you know
one of the inputs
i mean but also you could you could do
these tricks at the input layer
if you do some program analysis and say
that oh someone will know what's on this
wire
you can do that but this is this is for
an arbitrary and gate in the middle of
the circuit
we'll introduce these extra gadgets
to make one person so one person learns
a random bit that somehow helps the
uh helps use these little gadgets so
this is foreign there's no more
polynomial interpolation so there's a
totally different approach for
this phenomenon how did it compare to
the cost of the cash or whatever because
i would imagine it could be
easily cheaper
i don't think anyone implemented it
because i think
yehuda knows using the new
intel instruction set has actually an
instruction which helps to do financial
operations
and if you use that and highly highly
optimize everything it's about half and
a single alias operation
so it's not actually free i mean if
you're either it's not for free on top
of the and it's quite
it's not so easy to implement it's not
so difficult but it's about half an hour
or it is uniformly a random thing you
can optimize the circuit
approximated
that sounds like a great research
question you should join the dark side
and
do variable circuits with me
he wants to know if you can optimize
some of this garbling stuff if you know
that some of the inputs are going to be
randomly distributed instead of like
worst case
um i think i'm running a little low on
time
oh so here's here's my prediction um
right uh someone in 2026 is going to put
a new entry in this table it's going to
be all zeros
and then cryptography is going to be
over
but actually in our half gates paper
we show that that's okay there actually
is a floor
to how how good these can be right
nothing is for free
every every construction that i showed
you
what kind of tools does it use in its
toolbox well it calls a symmetric
primitive
like a prf or a hash function and it
uses linear operations like xor
or polynomial interpolation with with
fixed coefficients so that's just a
linear combination
we proved that if you're only using
these kind of operations
then you really do need to uh garble an
and gate with two ciphertexts so
whether or not you're compatible with
free xor just if you want to garble a
single and gate
and you're allowed to do anything you
like as long as it's one of these
linear operations then you do need two
ciphertexts so like i'm two is the
is the floor of how efficient these
things can be
that means that our half gates
construction is optimal in terms of
size right so size is the parameter i
care about for this talk
it's optimal among uh schemes that use
known techniques this is our
formalization of known techniques um and
schemes that work
gate by gate in an xor an and and not
basis
right you can't have an xor better than
free and you can have an and gate better
than two
not gates are also free which i didn't
mention so that makes the half gates
construction optimal
you know subject to these restrictions
maybe there is some negligible
probability of failure and then
the fact that things are linear means
that if you know if these linear
equations hold with noticeable
probability they probably hold
with that with with probability one
i didn't think about that in the proof
but i i think it probably
also covers the negligible error
yeah like so all these optimizations
look at one gate at a time is it
possible that maybe if you looked at
sort of
several gates together you could get
something better like maybe you could do
two psychic
you might be a timeless or something
like that that's the guy sitting next
um that oh my goodness what
where did this come from so so given
given this lower bound you know lower
bound shouldn't serve to like
deter us from doing anything ever it
just points us to where we should look
you know where we should break the rules
now and um
right one thing you can do is take a
larger chunk of the circuit don't
don't express it as individual gates
take a big chunk garble that as a whole
maybe you can do better valerio's giving
a talk
wednesday or thursday tomorrow
about just that there's ways to do
better than the half gates construction
by
by taking this approach
the lower bound was for linear garbling
schemes and maybe there's a clever way
to
do non-linear things like maybe you
interpret a wire label
as an element of a finite field and take
its inverse or
or multiply two wire labels together i
got i don't know
but that would be worth looking into or
maybe things can be cheaper that way
i put this up here just for the sake of
completeness i don't know if the
we have ways of garbling circuits that
are asymptotically better right they
have like
additive overhead instead of constant
overhead in the size of the circuit
but these use heavy machinery and they
uh it's not clear that those will ever
break even in terms of
things that you would want to implement
um
no if you continue on this linear uh yes
sir
and the last thing i don't think uh
i don't think the organizers are giving
me much more time how much more time do
i have
five minutes um yeah there's i can i can
do this
there's there's there's one more uh
there's one more optimization
that i think is really clever it's
sometimes you observe that you're using
garbled circuits
and you don't need the full the full
suite of security properties of garbled
circuits you actually need something
slightly weaker
which can lead to a concrete improvement
so
the the example of i know that i know of
is
uh is the zero knowledge proof uh with
the
claudio and others so alice wants to
prove a zero knowledge
prove a statement in zero knowledge to
uh bob
x is the win x is the instance and w is
the witness
and here's how you do it using garbled
circuits this is really elegant
when you teach yao's protocol in your
class
the next lecture you can teach this
protocol it's perfect
so the verifier generates a garbled
circuit that
checks the np relation so this is a
circuit with one
output wire label it's a single bit use
ot
to let the verifier pick up the uh the
garbled input
corresponding to the witness then
instead of announcing that garbled
output have the prover commit to the
garbled output that's like one wire
label commit to that wire that output
and from a verifier's point of view the
verifier is thinking
well at this point the prover knows a
garbled circuit and knows
a garbled encoding of uh the witness
and so if this commitment contains the
true
output wire label that means he must
have known a witness that causes the
the circuit to output uh true and this
this is the authenticity property
of garbled circuits that i talked about
much earlier
but why are we committing to it instead
of just revealing it because
the verifier might be corrupt the
verifier might have sent a bogus garbled
circuit that leaks everything about the
witness
so we have the verifier open the garbled
circuit and the approver will say that
okay if this is the garbled circuit
if the garbage circle was generated
correctly that means that the garbled
output that i committed to
it reveals nothing about my witness it
just reveals the fact that the
relation was true um we sort of checked
the verifier for correctness
and if it's correct then we can open the
groundwork circuit or open the
the the garbled output everyone's happy
and the whole reason we can evaluate a
garbled circuit and then later
open it open the same one like that's
kind of a
thing that you don't see every day it's
because the prover knows
the prover knows all the inputs to this
circuit already
the prover knows w there are no secrets
inside of this circuit
so opening the circuit doesn't leak
anything about say the verifier's input
the verifier didn't have any private
input
the only property we needed of the
garbled circuit was this authenticity
property
in particular we didn't need the privacy
property
and so in a follow-up work so
frederickson nielsen orlando
observed that in this protocol it's
secure if you just use
a garbled circuit scheme with
only the authenticity property and in
fact if you take out the privacy
property
you can get a smaller garbled circuit
you can get an and gate that costs only
one
for example use the use one of our half
gates from the half gates paper
so we already said if the evaluator of
the circuit knows
only one of the inputs to an and gate it
can cost one and in this
in this scenario the evaluator knows
both
so so this definitely uh works and it's
you know half as
half as large yeah don't you need the
adaptively secure
grabble circuit on the previous one oh
yeah i totally cheated in all of my
things in reality you would do the ot
first and then the grumbled circuit
second
i i for some reason this makes more
sense to my brain so i presented this
way but you're right this
this has an ad activity problem but you
just exchanged the order you're right
uh there's some subtleties that i didn't
uh there's a selective failure thing so
you need a committing ot the way you
open
the garbled circuit is is by having this
be a committed ot
you open up all the input wire labels
that's the way you open the circuit
and that ties it to the ot and there's
no selective failure but
the advantages it's already negligibly
solved yeah
yeah so there's details that i'm
glossing over you guys
i can't get anything past this audience
though um
okay so in some settings you only need
the authenticity property you can get
even smaller um
so that's interesting as well so uh so
that's
that's it for my talk i just want to go
back and and uh
appreciate where we've been in the last
30 years so i think garbled circuits
have
been a great success story for crypto is
something we should all be proud of
um uh the fact that aes
circuit is 10 times smaller than it was
in 1990 a garbled circuit
computation is sped up by many orders of
magnitude i think it's a great success
story
and there's still cool things to
discover and
so i hope you all stop working on
whatever you're doing and go work on
garbled circuits
and that's the end of my talk so thanks
yeah we're running a little bit late so
maybe we'll just go straight to the
break